hello and welcome to the new world
review i'm grand line waifu and today we
are being a super super sneaky
shh we're going to delve into the
moralistic side of hunter hunter with
discussion on the greater good versus
the absolute good and see what we make
of it all
let's get into episodes 98 and 99.
episode 98 and it's all about morality
something's going on with kilwa but
interestingly after spending a lot of
time in his head
he's now a bit of a hidden entity for us
there's friction between the two of them
in terms of what gone can do at what
kilwa can do and where kiwa used to be a
hugely submissive character that seems
to be dissipating as the effect of his
brother's needle wears off
either way kilo is not willing to
compromise on the situation and i'm not
sure
why beyond the knowledge that he can
move faster or do things
alone i'm sure there's more to it than
that and i'm sure i'm missing some stuff
but for now that's kind of what i think
about it despite knowing the chameleon
was behind them
kilwa deliberately split up he knew for
a fact that gone would not be able to
stay hidden so he's effectively using
gone as bait for the chameleon dude
compare this situation with
every prior one in which kilwa protected
gone and it's clear something about him
is very different
it may be that he's being harsh for the
sake of the mission or because he feels
for kite or
because he wants gone to achieve his
goals because that's something that he's
firmly had in mind throughout this but
it's fascinating seeing kilwa do what
his dad wants and take the lead which is
very much in the nature of him sort of
moving back toward his family origins
towards that story that we left behind
like two i wasn't here was it right it
was a while anyway
as interesting as it is to see him using
his assassin training and learnings in
earnest the way he
is i'm concerned as an aside i always
thought gone's mental steaming was a
metaphor for an overloaded brain
to both see it come out and focus to
acknowledge and shut it down was a
strange sight from my perspective it's
been very much about how we see inside
god's mind or don't because we can't be
inside a steaming brain there's no space
silly i expected him to be concerned
not slightly frustrated which is how the
actor played it and it's fully
understandable there's no space in this
mission for vulnerability
and gone and knuckle are our emotional
weak points
despite the things that have come up
both kiwa and coward guy
are the reason why any of this plan or
at least their part in it could succeed
the same could be said for white
morpheus and dude trinity white morpheus
is a loose cannon that can hold it
together for the job and i think he will
they all have shockingly similar
archetypes to play in this so
we will have to see who ends up being
the weakest link and in what way
to look at it differently gone and kilwa
could one day become knuckle and coward
who
could one day become morpheus and
trinity i love the idea of gone with
teeny glasses and killer with slicked
down hair so i'll just enjoy that moment
i'll enjoy that image for a moment just
because they're
in different stages of development
doesn't mean that what we saw wasn't one
scene repeating
three times the scene played out and
each time it was slightly different just
how different i guess we'll see in the
next episode meanwhile
it was all political the king of the
savannah fell in with the actual king
and they're currently a backdrop for all
the
internal issues of east gorton gorto
goring that toe speaking of east gorto
the
like i don't know five minutes kilo
spent explaining things it better not
just be tagashi deciding to detail the
world for funsies and then sharing it
with us
because it felt shoehorned i understood
that they're infiltrating and i
know we need to understand the stakes
and situation to a degree but sometimes
often when gone steams actually it feels
like tagashi just wanted to make sure he
doesn't waste his creativity by cutting
things out or maybe it's just that the
discussion is too much or too clunky for
the animation and the art that's trying
to contain it i do wonder sometimes
whether if tagashi were well enough he'd
have cut most of this out and made a
world companion guide with all the world
law instead interestingly that could be
fascinating and i'd love to develop a
tabletop game where you get to roleplay
through the hunter exam
and encounter things in the world anyway
now that i'm done steaming quietly
i'm not too sure what to make of
chameleon guy did kiwa go off to do his
own thing or is he going to turn up and
kill
merode he's a stealthy guy after all and
despite the shift in leadership i wonder
whether all that softness for gone is
gone or if it's just because he's afraid
or busy
i guess he's busy he has a lot to do in
his head constantly
because that's kilah the incredibly
poorly hidden massacre of the town and
the
severely extreme lengths they went to to
hide that people were
gone i don't know how cute i picked up
on the bloodstains or noticed that a
chair was so expertly hiding the
situation from those who lived in east
corto
those people must how
it wasn't covered up kiwa it wasn't
covered up i just
i don't know what to do i don't know
what to say to you dude it wasn't
everything that happened was a way to
show the extent to which the stakes are
being set we keep being given numbers to
qualify the level of concern
i personally have no concept of what one
million people
look like it's hard to consider numbers
that large in any real terms but
takashi's trying to make serious points
about scale the number of dead the
number that must die the number they
must kill
and then we have gone punching a sneaky
dude bryan refusing to kill even him
not off to a good start if gone's
already behaving like knuckle
it's like killua said ages ago knuckles
too soft and pacifist i'm not too sure
what that says about gone but if we go
back to the concept that all three
impulsive and emotional characters don't
actually want to use their abilities to
kill it makes the defeat of the ant
somewhat challenging
three of the group believe in the
greater good it doesn't make them feel
good but it leads to better outcomes
the other three seem to believe in
absolute good and the morality of
killing and i don't think that can be a
good thing in this context
psychologically greater good thinking
will save more people and be healthier
for the characters
absolutism is an ideal and you can't
make functioning plans based on
absolutes
as it is every plan is perfect until it
comes into contact with reality so let's
just see how reality plays out in
episode
99 episode 99 and about that absolutism
there was a cute little metaphor in the
episode that i'd like to touch on
moral morale morale i had to go ask liam
what his name is cause
white morpheus didn't fit morel goes on
a rant about his morels
i guess and trinidad reads the secret
garden while he does
i'm a huge fan of the use of sheen on
glasses that turns up in anime because
it gives us these clues as to what
characters are trying to hide or
sometimes it makes things crystal clear
about the lack of sway in the character
like shinji's dad who i think is
actually a hugely emotional character
but let's not get into that right now
that's not necessary
the blocking of glasses is always very
specifically done to emphasize a point
and here it's used to counterbalance
another behavior trinidad nov is showing
he's reading and he's reading the secret
garden which is a metaphor in a number
of ways for the current situation
the secret garden could be escorto of
course but within it is magic and
healing too
the little piece that is placed right in
the scene might
indicate nov's stance on the situation
and in fact at first the way his
movements were so stilted and blocked
and i feel
like that was more than usual i very
specifically wondered and
still do whether he's a plant and
actually sits on the board of the
hunters association
or if he's actually an ant already
which seems to have more control over
the way hunters live and work than i
thought they did or maybe i hadn't
really
thought about it the important thing is
that nov is keeping himself in check and
expressing himself through the media he
chooses to engage in
because he could be reading anything
takashi could have written
anything on that book i'm a huge fan of
knowing what
exactly characters are reading and when
they choose to read that morale
took the book away was a big sign of
both his desire to drag
nov into his perspective and nob's
desire to stay
in a place of healing but nov wasn't
swayed and that's a significant point
because
let's move on to the younger pair
knuckle and shoot fell apart this
episode they left their posts
and the plan has more uncertainty
introduced into it every time one of
these pairings
break from whatever the plan actually is
which i'm fairly sure requires them to
you know
deal with people together instead of
splitting up constantly
just like morel taking the potential of
serenity healing and growth from nov
knuckle took it from shoot
they can't just let people die can they
of course not but that tiny departure is
a huge departure from what they're
supposed to be doing which is letting
others handle the squadron leaders
that hunters haven't managed to take
down the squadron leaders is a concern
in itself and suggest that maybe the
ants are further flung already than they
were before
all they need if you recall is a single
ant to breed and the process continues
so now we have
gone and keel are separated with keela
doing what he does best which is
wreaking havoc and gone doing what he
does best which is punching things and
magically managing to make a difference
only to be manipulated into behaving
counter to the plan
that combat between gone and the ants
was enjoyable to watch come to think of
it i
enjoy seeing gon learn as he acts and
it's so counter to him thinking about
anything outside of combat
it's almost like his steam outlet gets
opened while he's fighting so it doesn't
get overcharged and he can put the
mental energy to use
that's the only way i can characterize
it because otherwise i'm getting mad
again that he's too clever to be
steaming at all
the existence of an albat gorilla combo
was great to see and actually it took me
back to the initial episode of gone
catching the fish
we know that gone has heightened senses
we've seen him smelling the ground and
tracking we've seen him hunting ahsoki
he is a naturally derived character and
that's a powerful being to see at work
watching him heft a tree was freeing and
hilarious and i loved the frame of him
pulling at it the hesitation in it and
the sequence of frames was chaotic and
fun just fun which is now that i think
about it
something we haven't really seen in a
while similarly
seeing kilwa doing his thing was
beautiful he's a force to be reckoned
with and it feels like after taking a
back seat to gone for so long he's
coming back into his own
we're seeing the nonchalant quick
thinking clear kid we saw in the first
arc and i
love that in fact across these episodes
that's what's changed and maybe that's
what gonz noticed
he's not doubtful of himself anymore
there's no self-doubt he's just doing
what he's doing and
doing it well enough that a certain cat
bug wants to hunt him down
but that's where our last pairing sits
because we've got a butterfly elinist
sitting tight in their stronghold to
look after their king because that's the
real task
they know it's a play to pull them away
from mary but they're not playing into
it and damn i love it when villains are
intelligent enough not to do the really
obvious thing
right away like it's uh yes there is
something about an intelligent villain
yes i'm looking forward to seeing where
we jump to next because frankly i'm not
seeing any protagonists at the moment
just a jumbled assortment of characters
including a new one in the new end
credits
it's great to see kyla looking up and
strong and proud now but who's that
random little one at the end
is that colt's baby put a super powerful
tantruming teenager against a toddler
and let the toddler win that's how it
would happen in real life come on since
i want to know
that's going to be it from me and colt's
baby if you enjoyed this odd
moralistic simplistic fatalistic
discussion of the world click
over here and here like share and
subscribe and i'll see you next time